something that has made a huge impact on
me and I think more people need to take
advantage of it which is transparent
numbers so basically there's a group of
people out there who believe that
transparency is good and they share all
of their revenue they chair they share
their every metric about their business
as deep as everyone's salary their bank
balance churn how much it cost to
acquire customer how much a customer
stays on for everything some are a
little bit less will they'll share how
many customers they have how much
revenue they have what the bank balances
more people should follow these
businesses I for one and totally against
that I don't think you should ever
reveal that but I'm happy they do and
yeah and so some examples so thorough so
first of all my friend encore
what's encores last name he runs
teachable I remember his last name if
you google it can you tell me on course
last name founder of teachable okay so
he reveals on Twitter the valuation of
every round what is it Matt Paul yes no
I said nog Paul NOC Paul he reveals the
valuation of every right every time they
just really 20 million bucks yeah duh
whatever 100 something really good and
he reveals how much revenue they have
how many customers they have it's
awesome yes I love that the other guy is
Sahil Sahil from Gumroad shitty business
seems like an awesome guy he reveals
every single month yeah oh you could
Google Gumroad founder Sahil it's on
just Twitter if you just he doesn't have
a tweet lane sitting after you don't
even have to dive into the books so yeah
here's Tom forty characters um Joel from
buffer he does this they actually just
switch so if you go to bear metrics comm
or google bear metrics they have like 18
different companies that do this and
it's pretty cool and Joel from buffer
used to be on there there are 22 million
dollar your company so pretty valuable
and they were well they feel everything
every employee salaries like name salary
equity you know level everything and you
know what they're changing they're
showing less and less because have you
talked to him do you know why it becomes
problematic when you add more people
yeah duh
you know guy you know creates you know
turns his kitchen into a man cave
instead gets a girlfriend and it's like
oh she doesn't like it it's like yeah oh
[__] man like I told you this like when
you bought the plasma and put it on the
fridge people don't like their salary
being public people get upset when they
see their co-worker who slacks off and
works from home two days a week and they
say because people understand that like
different people have different
situations it's not like so so they did
it I think in a smart way which is they
basically were like they use it as
customer acquisition yeah it's part of
their story because they got their ass
kicked by HubSpot and so they like you
know this has become a bit of a playbook
for small business of business SAS
companies which is look you know
acquisition of customers is hard if my
customer is a small business owner what
a small business what would bring a
small business owner to me what content
could I put out there that would make a
small business owner come so instead of
saying seven tips to have more effective
meetings they were like here's our
here's our P&L for this month and sure
enough a lot of people wanted to see
that so a lot of people discovered their
product through this and so you know
maybe this lines up totally with their
values and that's why they did it but I
just def mom definitely it was a great
way for people to discover their
business I didn't use buffer but I read
all their [__] and if anybody ever
needed a solution like buffer I was like
Oh buffer you should use buffer why
because otherwise I wouldn't have even
known about them and so this was a
pretty counterintuitive thing that they
did and they were the only ones doing it
and so you always get paid when you're
the only one doing it if it's juicy yeah
and so one more person who's doing it
and his business is way better than
buffer I love this guy's business so
it's my friend Nathan berry I've met
Nathan a while ago and Nathan has this
company called convertkit they do close
to two million monthly recurring revenue
so 24 million he owns 100% of it it's
right it's probably a hundred to two
hundred million dollar company like it's
really valuable because once customers
are locked in it's basically a MailChimp
competitor it's an email that seems high
to two million a month you said - oh
that's for sure how much they do know
that part that
twenty-four million a year so 24 million
you think they're worth what ten times
ten times that okay maybe throwing like
a weed maybe people don't switch from
their email platform yeah it all depend
on the retention so can you pull up
actually can you open it open up their
their metrics so just as hi just Google
like like bear metrics dashboard or
something I forgot what the URL is but
it's like something dot bear metrics
comm and it's like their whole company
it's like here's how many new customers
we got here's how many people churn this
month it's like all their graphs and you
can use it for your company he even
showed how much profit they make I think
it's like convert kit it's like yeah
here it is there you go so this I don't
know if this is their business so this
is like the example thing but it's like
monthly recurring revenue net revenue
fees this is somebody else convertkit
yeah do convertkit bear metrics I've
been convertkit
revenue maybe I also use convertkit I
actually I pay for subscription because
I'm like this product is so [__]
powerful I don't actually have many
sequences set up I have a sequence of
one email right now which is not a
sequence it's just an email
but I think it's a great product I love
convertkit
I love Nathan Nathan's a great guy
Nathan's only twenty six or seven years
old we talked to we talked about the
idea of doing a drip sequence to build a
newsletter for women going through
pregnancy and like week by week and I
had a friend are sorry now random
listener reach out on Twitter is like
I'm doing this here's my kind of unique
asset I have to go about this and how
should I set this up and I sent them to
convertkit I was like dude your problem
is gonna be solved in like you know the
next 90 minutes what are people leaving
bare mattress um why can't you find it
here you go
1.7 million oh is that it what's the URL
yeah so 1.7 million monthly recurring
revenue and you could just look at the
turn so annual run right doing 20
million a year which is up 1.7 percent
that's got to be how much this month
revenue-sharing 5.1 percent per month
it's not great either well it's because
it's a small to medium business like if
you're turning five percent a month
that's like what's isn't what's the net
growth so five percent a month is the
churn what's the new business every
month one and a half one half percent
yeah so he's net negative then per month
no I think that that churn growth month
that growth number takes into account
churned actually okay gotcha
okay that's the but this is because it's
the the average revenue even says so
they make on average $60 is it $60 a
month per user right and on the right
one of medium business gonna have a how
it's gonna have higher and compared to
other SAS but if you're a real sicko you
can just look at the live shame on the
right and see every minute when somebody
pays them it'll say like right now it
says twenty million dollars paid by you
know anonymous company dude he's got a
lot of failed payments here and get on
that Nathan what's going on you can't be
failing is three out of the twelve
payments here failed for he has a chart
so these these companies are badass I
you wouldn't do it no I think what about
a part of what you do but email list
size the revenue I don't want to share
anything publicly I'll say like eight
figures or write something no I just
don't think it brings a lot of good
either you know when a company's trying
to raise or sell their business because
like two months before all these
articles will come out just like handing
over they're handing over information
why is that happening because they want
to raise the ground they want to sell
their company in the next six months I
don't know I'm not a fan of it at one
time when I when I did my first
conference when I was younger it made
like 60 grand in profit and I told
everyone in the blog post and I hated
the attention so I'm never gonna do it
again
[Music]